Our business focuses us on diversity because
we all work in a sport that was deemed too
black to thrive and actually even survive.
People forget, but there were articles, “The
Dark Clouds Over the NBA…”
I literally – when I was executive vice
president Larry sent me up to a newspaper
and the television guy said, “You don’t
get it, Stern.
You guys are just not going to make it.
This is a white country and you have a black
sport.”
So we developed chips on our shoulder early
on.
If you worked at the NBA in the 70s you had
to be a believer that America was a good country
and that we had something to teach rather
than to be afraid of.
A sport that, you know, could have Willis
Reed from Louisiana and Grambling and Bill
Bradley from Crystal City, Missouri and Princeton
on a championship team, hmmm, that says something
about a sport that has something to teach.
That’s about talent.
We sort of rallied around the notion that
if you came to an NBA game it didn’t matter
where you sat, you know, whether you were
in the nosebleed section or at court side,
your opinion counted regardless of your race.
And if you were on the court, your talent
counted regardless of your race.
You got game, you play.
If you don’t have game, you don’t.
And so this was a subject of some discussion
at the NBA always on an ongoing basis.
And it has ramifications throughout our whole
business.
When I was required to act when Ron Artest
ran into the stands in Detroit and there was
a big brawl, et cetera, the talk radio that
weekend – the words "thugs" and "punks"
was uttered what seemed to be about a million
times.
I’m sure it was less but we all know the
code words.
And so we tend to be particularly protective
of our players in that regard and I think
it makes us conscious of a lot of different
things having to do with the racial discussion.